sehen sie dann verwirkt
[Gelächter]
ich habe nicht gesehen eigentlich nach
lieferbeziehung von zwei erwachsenen
menschen und der heute 44 mal die
chronik oder vori vier monitore und
kunden rui
nein das ist es nicht was sie also ist
jetzt groß was sagt sie
[Musik]
yvonne ist geschieden und lebt seit acht
jahren in einer frauen wohngemeinschaft
sie hatte sich gut eingerichtet
auch ohne partner war sie zufrieden
meistens ich bin 26 jahre lang zwischen
220 und 74
mit ihrem mann hat sie drei kinder
großgezogen und ist heute zweifache
großmutter nachher und dann ist mit
gurke und eigentlich 260 akkord nicht zu
machen
dann habe ich verdrückt wassersport
duschen und dieses prinzip mit die
natürlich kann ich sie auch die
vorschauen unmöglich finde ja dann hanni
saphirglas ebenso freie warm und
erfahren und lustig und älter und alles
gute
und dann ich von meinem aus einzig
wollen einfach gerade braucht milch
stinkt uns läuft zeichen
jeden morgen allein am frühstückstisch
zu sitzen allein durch die botanik zu
streifen immer alles allein tun zu
müssen darum suche ich 69 jährige
optimistisch junggebliebene schlank
lebens und unternehmungslustige radlerin
wanderin genießerin und raum zürich
lachen und einem unter luschkow das
inserieren einfach wie ist es
außergewöhnlich sich nicht verkrampft
original nicht alles das finale ab ohne
alte leute die fürchterlichen bestätigen
sondern einfach sagen ich denke ich
werde sehen ja ich habe gerade geschickt
also gerade sich öffentlich bekannt
gemacht bei mir und schreibe und den
leserinnen duzen sich inserat hat mir
gefallen
schau halt ob ich diese worte und das
bild ansprechend und sonst bitte aus
zurück y
franz hat mehrere beziehungen und eine
ehe hinter sich
seine zwei buben sind längst erwachsen
und franz ist seit ein paar jahren
leidenschaftlicher großvater
es war sommer 2017 und franz ging es
eigentlich ganz gut ohne partnerin
er wohnte zwar alleine fühlte sich aber
nicht einsam
[Musik]
aber manchmal fehlte ihm eben doch etwas
und darum reagierte erfreut
als yvonne auf seine anrufe antwortete
sofort die dazu da und halb geschrieben
das hat mir gefallen und sinnlicher und
c a dressur und im sinne otti ja die hat
mich begeistert durch drees blick muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen
und trotzdem nicht gefunden hat
ja ich kann kanzler dann habe jemand aus
dem profiteam karl der große und ich an
dem buch zum großen blumenstrauß für
mich nicht folgen dinge wo ich mich
regelmäßig und hat sich nicht geschont
main geboren bin ich in allem kann der
großen sofort dass er sich ich denke
dass wir hatten kann da hat man viel
besser gefallen wirklichkeit als auf dem
foto
er hat ein wunderschöner pro bestellung
vorsicht mit für mich sondern für sie -
frauen tätig und dann habe ich einen
ganzen lebens würdigen mensch keine
gräten handel ganzer offene entspannte
stunden womit immer gute gefühl als
trend hand und lust qantas fortsetzen
sie haben einfach fasziniert von mir
stimmung also ich nicht fahren in love
platz drin sondern es ist es auch ein
studio stellen und lebensglück 17 und
platz nehmen
[Musik]
in zermatt hat pierre sein spätes glück
gefunden
da war er 67 jahre alt sport war dem
geschäftsmann immer wichtig verheiratet
war hat er aber immer lange beziehungen
meist zu viel jüngeren frauen
dieses jahr wird er 79
[Musik]
so drohen ist bald 75 jahre alt über 30
jahre war sie glücklich verheiratet ohne
kinder
[Musik]
sie war friseuse mit eigenem geschäft in
deutschland
[Musik]
vor 35 jahren kam sie mit ihrem mann das
erste mal nach zermatt und es gefiel
ihnen sehr er aber plötzlich war sie mit
anfang 60 wieder allein und nach fünf
jahren habe ich meinen dabei auch gerade
so dass meine mutter starb die alt war
meine schwester die serie war mein
geschäft gerade aufgegeben als ich war
frei irgendwie war frei mit dem tod bin
ich besser klargekommen
und ja und da war ich wieder offen
es hat mir jemand gefehlt ich hab immer
wieder bin ich noch mal den richtigen
treffe dann sage ich nicht nennen also
ich möchte nicht immer alleine sein und
eben nach fünf jahren
ich bin mit dem freund der in zürich
lebt mit dem ich mich eben hier immer
getroffen habe aber war wie mein sohn
und da war mir halt auch hier drin
und ja und saskia eben hier und hat
gemerkt dass ich eben nicht zu dir mein
gehör neue sonic merkt sofort merkte
meinte sie
naja okay er hat halt auf mich
aufgepasst
es ist das magnetfeld lomi lomi fast so
gehabt
hintergründe und portugal
da stehen im notfall dafür schickte das
magnetfeld den chefstuhl nicht
beschrieben dass das werden stromschlag
verwirklicht
sie beschrieben
kannst du machen aber nichts verloren
ist hat nichts zu verlieren bin als frei
die dann hat es gestattet die zwei
wochen wunderschön danach nicht so
lästern ja dass so gut es gibt es gar
nicht die gefühle bleiben das ist egal
wie alt man ist die haut die hülle
wir waren richtig ekelig aber das gehört
und es ist sehr schön
[Musik]
ja weil man nicht so viel erwartet man
hat nicht zu diesem erfolgsdruck
man lässt es einfach so man riecht nicht
nach ungewollten kind noch retten ist
und es muss nicht immer es ist auch sehr
lustig man nimmt es mit mehr humor ich
jedenfalls
und warum ist es ja wenn es mal nicht so
richtig klappt dann lacht man darüber
oder man sich sagt kommen der bäume
hinter uns und wir brauchen auch die
beiden alten hunden gebrauchen die wärme
aber nicht dazu da tut sich nix nicht
dass du denkst sie einfach nur es ist
einfach schön ich wünschte es hätten
viel mehr menschen
es macht glücklich oder nicht immer
glücklich also glücklich ist er auch
immer nur moment aber zufrieden
[Musik]
daher sie leben seit zwölf jahren als
paar zusammen und verbringen jeweils
mehrere monate im jahr in ihrem
sehnsuchtsort zermatt
[Musik]
felix löscher hat als architekt viele
häuser und kirchen gebaut
seine frau und er haben vier kinder
großgezogen
nach 20 ehejahren hat sie sich wieder in
ihren jugendfreund verliebt und
plötzlich stand er alleine da
versprochen dass wir zusammen bleiben
bis alles was sie sehen also und das ich
zeige organen oder und ich hoffe dass
ich überhaupt kein problem für mich
nachher gar nichts sagt jutta leidet sie
dann ist das dann ist das so ich fahre
jetzt
jetzt bin ich einfach allein hierdurch
niemand mehr erwarten so und das ist
wahnsinnig und ich hatte eingewandt ja
ich besuche von eco speed mit anderen
person oder anderer frauen oder so
teilen die bisher wirklich das überhaupt
andere und hat eine mal wieder jung ins
roth reagiert ich haben ihr bruder der
zweijährige nach einer partnerschaft die
es wahnsinnig im vordergrund stand und
ideen moment ihnen rund beim skifahren
in verliert sobald die begegnung mit dem
grauen hof turiner wie so oft hat der
kalten weiß nicht was du wunderst
denn überhaupt zivilisten die eigentlich
glücklich er hat ja schon grob
[Gelächter]
fahrlässig in die video vor allem
richtung an zum anderen so aussieht nun
auch nicht weit zurück übernahmen verein
gut sagt das und das heize ich komme
zeige schlafe wofür diese herrschaft und
ja herr schaffen aber und die heine-uni
telefonkabine und da nicht so viel
trainieren
ein brief geschrieben das wintertreffen
heimat und eine ist und diese keine
antwort und also jetzt liegt die einfach
und sie seit der wende
dann schlüpft sie in münchen
zitate nicht reagiert
wie vor die gewächse oder hauptstraße
und der akku leer und über 20 minuten
hat sie zukommt oder und da der pc
problem dass sie so und behauptet ich
sei als jene beträge wasser jährige zum
dritten mal urkundlich sie das wahre
opfer gefunden hat wo im alter so im
bereich sie sichtlich älter als sie und
aber auch nicht mehr mit
eurosport hat ja ihre späte liebe begann
vor 20 jahren
damals war sie 71 und er 64 sie sind oft
und weit zusammengerauft lebten aber in
getrennten wohnungen
vor elf jahren sind sie zusammen gezogen
in einer seniorenresidenz vor vier
jahren haben sie geheiratet
für marta war es das erste mal die vier
kinder und sechs enkel von felix sind
jetzt auch ihre familie marta war
chefsekretärin und in der freizeit
ballonpiloten für eine beziehung hatte
sie keine zeit aber eben da begegnete
ihr felix und es war um sie geschehen
marta war früher eine pionierin der
schweizer ballonfahrt nun zeigen sich
zunehmend symptome einer demenz wäre
alles mikros und die problemlos nicht
weil mir unterwegs ist die otto haben
wir probleme im wind und täusche über
hat sie erfahrung muss jeder weiß und
musik gedächtnis habe ich mich mit dem
umgang wählen weil die hippies kreiter
zwei minuten nach der frage diskutiert
wir haben am anfang fast täglich
reagierte zwar glück seid sich so
betrieb
das ist ganz klar ist normal erschien in
dem alter
und das ist für mich herausforderer
dörfer dass tante unterstützen so gut
und so lange ich das kann mein name ist
jeden tag als geschenk ohne große plan
haben was ich morgen und so hütet und
jetzt haben es schön und gemüse das was
mich
[Musik]
das auto sieht 2
da bist du sehr die jungs im
betagtenzentrum rosenberg in luzern
leben rund 120 pensionärinnen und
pensionäre die leiterin katja uhlemann
weiß um deren bedürfnisse auch in
liebesdingen natürlich sexualität bezirk
arabisches großes thema im durchschnitt
sind die menschen hier 87 jahre alt sie
brauchen eine sensible führung und
häufig ein offenes ohr
auch für liebesgeschichten für die es
selbst als bewohnerin oder bewohner
eines seniorenzentrums nie zu spät ist
ausnahmen gelten und des bauern worte
sind system eigentlich nicht ganz so
einfach da sind die könige natürlich da
wo unter umständen nieder so jetzt ist
hoch findet das irre vater oder ihre
mutter generiert durch die kürzlich das
nachfrage sind ja früher die partner
oder partnerinnen doch sie war völlig
verstorben sind ich glaube den er mit
dem umhängen das aushalten dass jetzt
die eigene modelinie verliebte teenager
dieser gegend beschwert
manchmal lebt ein ehepartner noch in der
alten wohnung
und der oder die andere bereits im
betagtenzentrum und teilt das zwei
zimmer mit einer fremden person wo jetzt
nicht essbar sind sondern wo jetzt
holzlager zusammengebracht hat wenn wir
jetzt nicht beginnen andere mensch
körperlich
das ist sehr schade ich mir immer sorgen
dass das außerhalb von rosenberg aus
stattfindet damit der schutz vor der
intimsphäre gewährleistet ist nicht nur
die mitbewohnerinnen und mitbewohnern
beobachten was in liebesdingen so läuft
im haus auch das personal muss sich
damit auseinandersetzen
sie müssen im team lösungen finden wenn
menschen sich einsam fühlen wünsche nach
sexueller stimulation äußern berührt
werden wollen oder eben nicht normal und
verständlich sind
es gibt aber natürlich auch bilden womit
sie wartet doch cruise ist man sollte
also tue bis zu bruch das noch bis
wartehaltung größere tradition man sagen
also in der eine spielothek sie und das
lange doch jetzt denn also da gibts da
gibt es wirklich alles so einige jahre
ein bewohner kam aber ganz klar gesagt
ich möchte gerne prostituierte und
meinten das glückt und händen gefunden
ich denke also mit einem zehn minuten
richtig das nicht möglich sei das weil
wir viel zu stigmatisieren dabei nicht
alles verloren meine rollstuhl und den
was gibt es da eigentlich eher nüchtern
und gab es für angebot ja dann hätte mir
im medium der sucht zeigt in dem der
zugang geschafft und den hätte das
natürlich den sorgen müssen organisiert
april hände in foren hat mir handy nach
wiederkommt mit dieser offenheit stößt
sie bei angehörigen oder auch
mitarbeitenden gelegentlich auf
unverständnis
mit den häufig sprache führen und sage
ja um was geht es denn jetzt also gott
zum mini persönliche werthaltig ohnehin
in bezug auf die art von dienstleistung
oder gott sitzung der mensch
[Musik]
ivo nun franz genießen seit neun monaten
ihre späte liebe
[Musik]
franz hat yvonne erzählt dass er an der
nicht heilbaren lungenkrankheit copd
leidet trotzdem oder vielleicht gerade
deshalb schmieden sie oft pläne
ich bin noch ganz viele sachen kann ich
mir vorstellen für den briten ein camper
und alles mögliche und ich mache mir
heute wirklich auch machen
das wasser h2o nachgefragt sich so
schwer in ordnung und hat so eine gute
und ich so entspannter und tut mir so
gut und bringt mich zum lachen und aber
vielleicht hatte mit der versucht ihnen
war ein wenig unter dass klebt oder mal
gegangen ich während ich find's einfach
ganze herne tief raum wo mich näher mit
dank an das ist das überhaupt möglich wo
so auf mich stehen durch mich auf meine
bedürfnisse und und damit mehr konten
von umgehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
strafen wo das versuche ich denke da
zeigt sich optimistisch index hielt sich
20 staaten auf der welt die und und er
sich nach doping hier kommt dem buch von
franz muss ich jetzt ganz ehrlich sagen
das beschauliche ja und die frauen
schweiz geht - endlich ist und sich
deshalb das team gut und zum 2 nein
ehrlich nachher gegen die die
zärtlichkeiten also dann in la vie
germanen schon dem wagen und lebe von
tennis wo ständig nehmen dich so lieb
von odewald dann will ich mein gott
der schlepper und alles möglich bitte
richtig berich konfiguriert haben
das ist alles so wichtig acht nicht wir
sind
mit grundsätzlichen bedenken
[Musik]
die 78 jährige yvonne lebte rund 20
jahre alleine ihren ersten kuss bekam
sie von peter damals war sie 17
die beiden haben sie seither also seit
59 jahren nicht mehr gesehen
dabei wohnte peter noch immer ganz in
der nähe
aber das wusste sie nicht peter ist
inzwischen 80 auch er hatte keine ahnung
dass sein ehemaliger schatz seit vielen
jahren gleich um die ecke liegt
erstaunlicherweise sind sie sich nie
begegnet
vor zwei jahren schien er allerdings an
von yvonne zu träumen
und er hat sich an die küsse von damals
erinnert
sie bedankt seine klamotten situation
natürlich im kino auf eingestand
aber plötzlich an ihrem trip von dass
sie mitmachen dass sie nicht mit 20
gehören nur so an der oberfläche
und wieso hund der in richtung wie die
rückbank ist und jetzt hat der fliegt
und dort büro dazu gehört die eigene 50
und froh ich habe in 2014 80 toten
nach langem ließen sich befriedigt sie
nachher wirklich trägt hier kann machen
was sie will und der hd verbringt sie
die elbseite kollege und sehr froh dass
ganz klar nichts über ihn hat hat auch
private sportredaktion ort zeigt in
cannes ganz normal mit 850 nennen wollte
und der brief von peter alexander dix
käthe lieblingen
hallo liebe erschrecke nicht
das lässt lässt mich nicht mehr los weil
ich keine telefonnummer von dir finden
schreibe ich dir seit einiger zeit
kommst du mir immer wieder im raum
verstehen wie schlecht ich suche keine
film
jetzt begrüßt linie optisch zwischen
zerstört als sie war und einige märkte
schon ganz aufgeregt nach all den jahren
haben sich die frisch verliebten
unglaublich viel zu erzählen und schon
beim ersten treffen offenbarte peter
yvonne dass er keine erektion mehr haben
kann
die unternehmen viel und besuchen sich
was täglich gegenseitig in ihren
wohnungen und sind überrascht wie viele
interessen sie teilen
trotz verliebtheit wollen sie nicht
zusammenziehen
weil sie die fallstricke kennen was
jetzt seine sich dem treffen und somit
da sehe ich oder der helm hat extra das
ist einfach frau sollte das update 14
und er ist vater das klinikum nicht so
auf messen und events erster punkt und
tut muss erhält herzfehler stoffjacke
ja das muss man einfach so ziemlich in
hardt das ganze frage mit ja
[Musik]
was ist das heißt sie pflegen auch ihren
freundeskreis wie bisher
es war zu sehen wie ich mich bis klassik
dass das so funktioniert und er ist
wirklich nicht viel übrig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dies passiere
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das schon verständlich
eine späte liebe zu finden braucht
manchmal mut und ausdauer
hans ist 80 und war zweimal verheiratet
der witwe lebt allein und er fühlt sich
einsam
und jetzt bin ich halte ein straftritt
es ist nicht einfach als eine
partnervermittlung anstrebe peter
bichsel resultat wenn wir befragt 80
abgeschrieben
das schaffe dann alter zwischen leben
und schien dort ganz lebendig zu sagen
und da das du diese schockieren und
jetzt wo nico schreiber habe trends
internet gibt es sind immer keine gruppe
eine frau ab 60 die noch eine beziehung
eingehen möchte das erste hochhaus ja
wir alt sind wieder schüsse
jetzt geht es natürlich liter der frau
aber sage ja mit 70 grad mit 80 bruch da
das nur für das wasser müssen aber für
durchschnitt ich kann ja nicht schreiben
was sie jesus gemacht aber ich
abgeschrieben wird das dort so weh und
wie sie muss geht ist das so wichtig
wichtig als das geht den thalia bücher
alters gk distanz und genüsse also wäre
schlimm basierte guter charakter ich
sehr lieb sagte und sachlichkeit geht
jetzt sehe ich mache davon können cap
und kopf spazieren über alles
diskutieren was ein blog artig das
wertvolle gut noch immer große ganze das
kann ich nicht wissen
das ist ein teil von ihm habe ich dann
sicher noch 0 44 jährige
das sei mehr als die jetzt das nicht
dass ich das sagt ich bin der chef der
schnur das ist klar aber dass der takt
rhythmus da fasziniert er verbessert
[Musik]
tanz nachmittage für senioren wie hier
in münchenstein sind beliebt als
partnerbörse
[Musik]
viele kommen allerdings schon als paar
das wiederum ist schwierig für singles
in der zweiten lebenshälfte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bedeuten
[Musik]
ja
auf der
[Musik]
ich gut
[Applaus]
vielleicht ergibt sich ja daraus etwas
wer weiß von franz sind seit einem jahr
ein glückliches paar
jetzt wollen sie tanzen lernen
[Musik]
und hat angst
doch du kannst du noch positives terrain
[Musik]
darmstadt
da
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also ich bin das naturbad ich das schon
dass bin hammam rim der tanzkurs kiefer
50 eur assist könig 60 umgerissen als
ganze bestimmt nein stimmt überhaupt
nicht
ich hatte schöne mein leben hoffen aber
dass die stadt aus dem stand genommen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich nicht bedroht so eine
hübsche die quicklebendige person ein
sprecher damals
[Musik]
ja wo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vonn hatte bevor franz in ihr leben kam
sehr viel zeit für ihre beiden enkel
diese müssen ihre großmutter jetzt mit
dem neuen partner teilen sich merkt dass
ihr witz legalität aber im guten sinne
was sie immer fix also findet zeit
verstand sondern ein großes geschenk und
als ein buch das hat uns die wenige
hirte aber das stört mich jetzt nicht
weil ich das gefühl habe führe machte
den tolle sachen überlegt man sich
manchmal was macht ihr buch die schlacht
größer so ein bisschen weg gerade wie
sie oder er sich glücklich und versorgt
das fest zum siebzigsten geburtstag von
franz ist für yvonne eine
herausforderung
die ganze verwandtschaft je älter man
ist umso mehr freunde bekannte kinder
und kindeskinder bevölkern 1 lieben die
gehören bei einer späten liebe dann halt
auch dazu ob es einem passt oder nicht
franzens exfrau und mutter der söhne hat
nichts gegen einzuwenden
genauso wenig wie die beiden söhne von
franz
plötzlich merkt das feld dritter wurde
das erzählt hat uns gehört und man
bekommt den eindruck franz spielt mit
seiner band heute vor allem filimon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der geschrieben die keine theorie
zwischen meister und der für mich glück
so eindrucksvoll xxi ich habe es in der
auflaufform autokratie mg und 100 die
letzte chance und diese aufgabe zum
irgendwie noch mal eine andere stufe und
geht ihm schon bundes jahr zahlen
[Applaus]
das rezept für eine späte liebe ein
bisschen mut vielleicht und wie es felix
und marca so schön sagen es habe grosse
großzügigkeit das haus jedes sind
lebensrhythmus und sie in trance und so
an und verfolgen kann
es ist nicht so dass wir es ihnen helfen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]